the jurgen experience gotta get off the
cbd oil man
it's mad it's right in your brain man
you can't be too relaxed
right yeah that's cbd [ __ ]
it saves vacations for me i don't
stress out like it's it's it's i think
it's one of the best things i've ever
tried for anxiety it's it's weird and i
didn't even know i had anxiety until i
started taking cbd
i take these little jammies these are
this is uh
this will [ __ ] you up though this is one
and one this is
one part cb don't put this in your butt
yeah do not put this in your body you
can put it in your butt but
you will get no nervous you're gonna get
paranoid but
it's a it's a weird like the cbd thc
high is a different high
because cbd does something to alleviate
anxiety
it sort of just like makes you
comfortable with your own demise
it lets you you the existential angst is
the flames don't seem so hot so you're
like yeah we're all going to die
yeah but right now we're not dead cool
look at the colors feel that feel the
warmth of the sun
but this uh this is not like funk this
is not functional
like you don't wanna i don't do this if
i have anything super important to do
but
but just cbd oil i just find it it
puts you in a great place okay like it's
internal not topical
internal yeah topical's really good for
muscle aches okay it's really good
really the probably the best thing i've
ever found for like a alleviating
soreness and stiffness and stuff like
that because i found i was just
in europe all of a sudden discovered
that they actually had
ibuprofen like cream to put on ibuprofen
is terrible for you
right really really bad and what i found
out was that
if you let your pets lick it they get
liver failure and
die whoa so don't did you just
accidentally do that no i had a person
who works with the humane society i
mentioned
you know mentioned that i found this
stuff like just in desperation and
europe like
had some sore muscles and uh she's like
don't let your pets
lick that because they were trying
they're trying to figure out why these
kittens were dying oh
god my friend cameron haynes is a runner
and he runs marathons and he runs ultra
marathons he runs these 240 mile
moab [ __ ] ridiculous
runs that last three days and he was
having like all this joint pain so he
was taking ibuprofen
every day taking 800 milligrams not just
once but sometimes twice a day
and he was just constant aches and pains
so dr rhonda patrick had been on the
podcast she was talking about the
dangers of ibuprofen and about what it
does to your
gut biome and how much it [ __ ] you up
and actually creates inflammation it
actually can cause stress
or it can cause strokes rather and all
sorts of horrible horrible things so i
call them up and i said hey man
that stuff's fine to take every now and
then for a headache but you can't take
that [ __ ] every day you
just can't do it and you're you're
[ __ ] your body up just get off of it
and i
sent him the recording he listened to it
he's like jesus christ i don't have a
stroke
so he gets off of it all his pain goes
away it turned out his pain
was being caused not just by the running
but
by the fact that he was creating
inflammation by destroying his gut biome
by taking
800 milligrams of ibuprofen two times a
day
so the idea of like fixing himself was
[ __ ] him up it's crazy that's chasing
that you know
yeah so [ __ ] ibuprofen okay well i mean
don't i mean i take it
every now and then but you can't take it
every day so you're a liar
no i'm just saying don't take it every
day but if i had like a bad headache
i'll take some tylenol or some [ __ ] it's
not tylenol right advil
yeah yeah i mean it's it's it's just not
something you're supposed to take all
the time
so it's yeah i did for a minute i
realized it was doing what you said
yes i was more icky than i should be and
then like you know
bad night out you didn't drink enough
water right okay
yeah then you're fine you can still do
that but cbd does that too
it's better better for you than all that
stuff there seems to be no side effects
okay all right the side effects is uh
people think you're a hippie that's the
only side effect
right